good morning Internet I'm Shaggy and
this is a very merry hahahahahahahahaha
news yeah that's copyrighted Chad oh
this God right yeah what's trendy right
now is Christmas gulfside stick your
tongue sending cold polls you come
across because hey it's Christmas and
that's now socially acceptable so go
like a pull metal pull that is Chad so
the folks behind cards against humanity
are just killing it this holiday season
last year those cheeky bastards student
protests Black Friday they actually
raised the price of the game which i
think is pretty smart now this year they
continued their attack and commercialism
by not selling their game on black
friday at all instead they promoted
their game through the ten days of
Kwanzaa or whatever and they sent
consumers a little teeny box of bullsh
it was six dollars for literal book I
would prefer coal personally and now
that the holiday season upon us I
thought this would be a fun opportunity
to bond with my fellow hashtag News
hosts so without further ado taha hey
guys hey Jan what's up I'm doing good
how are you I'm doing great we just been
sitting here yeah the whole time I
watching you from behind well you did
the intro I just pretended like you were
speaking from your butt the whole time I
actually can all right no I can't it's
stage fright James gonna do it kid's
gonna do it he's gonna do this in
college too all right after watching ace
ventura ready to play yes i'm also ready
to play DZ we're kids on a beach you're
gonna get i sleep at night oh I can't
one day
sleep at night I'll tell him why I got
it Ted can't sleep at night because it
is an asymmetric pooja Oh Ted you got
that asymmetric boob job Ted they said
hey good thanks all right here we go
because of an M night Shyamalan plot
twist oh he's a real movie buff
everybody Ted can't sleep at night
because he's concealing a boner oh that
was yours we know the donor before my
god I can't wait till you okay I'm sorry
find out who wins this round 10 I my
boners make it hard from you oh I
haven't been picking new ones have you
guys know you know I say pretty
confident my deck my big deck I don't
really need to like I don't need to make
my deck any bigger you know I mean like
the size of my deck are you trying to
say rack is before Gabe runs for
president he must destroy all evidence
of his involvement with the car you know
his name is Lonnie the card says if Gabe
was running for president he would have
to destroy all evidence of his
involvement with getting hilariously
gangbanged by the Blue Man Group oh I
didn't know that these cards were true
it's like their fortune teller I don't
think there's anything true or hilarious
about if game runs for president he's
gonna have to destroy all involvement
with exactly what you'd expect
personally I would have thought it was
hilariously being gangbanged by the Blue
Man Group okay if gay before were to run
for president he have to short all
evidence that he was ever involved in
bath mates was that you were and that
was your class i doing I wasn't gonna
pick the gang bang one was I haha you
want to be funny this was the one I was
gonna choose what spectacular abs I'd
have to destroy all
talk I said to it oh I think I'm gonna
go spectacular nobody in EM night
shyamalan snoo movie Bruce Willis
discovers that blank had really been
blank all along mr. clean right behind
you was really whipping a disobedient
slave we all know is that was and I
didn't get a point panda sex was really
leaving an awkward voicemail Bruce
Willis discovers that the force has
actually been sexual tension Oh all time
I'd vote for that I believe Gabe has 11
i have 0 0 & E's it's so hard I'll say
my own day I don't make anyone say my
name its most likely gonna say get ready
get ready with these cards but we still
need the cards and minutes passer la la
lifetime presents blank the story of
blank giving a hundred and ten percent
the story of sniffing glue starring in
that was right nice appeared all right
this Christmas lifetime presents
nunchuck moves the story of online
having a stroke that's pretty good new
lifetime movie the gays the story of my
inner demons ah I might have just come
out Burt so who won I might I think we
have to make it Chad yeah because he
just came out and we're really
supporting it sure just give it to Chad
dad I just want you to know that now
that you beat us and cards against
humanity with that you better be gay
Gabe how do you feel about the loss I
thought it was kind of fixed the whole
thing hey go ahead play on that way oh
oh no minor demons we're gonna do
something special now we're gonna sing a
little song y'all ready yeah transition
one weekend oh yeah we're gonna in honor
of the ten days of Kwanzaa expansion
pack coming out we're gonna sing the ten
days of Kwanzaa to the tune of twelve
days of Christmas I don't even know
Kwanzaa had a song well it's about 20 we
gonna do is pick a new card for every
day okay sing through it let's see how
much of a train wreck this is yeah lower
the volume on your computers because I
have a terrible voice let's go new track
is over here on the tenth day of Kwanzaa
my true love gave to me 10 keg stands
nine party pooper eight rock music and
premarital sex 70 linh sex porn stars
fine
lady gaga for all poop inside of my body
three is three boats I mutilated images
for 200 years of slavery lies many oz of
you I am a better singer than I thought
make sure you like this video also make
sure you subscribe to new media rock
stars and also why don't you go ahead
and leave a comment what should they
comment guys maybe their favorite person
in this video yeah all right well one of
us is getting fired next we'll see you
guys next time later on the tenth day of
Kwanzaa my true love gave to me a
blockbuster late fees up the wazoo